[Music]
so
[Music]
hello good morning it's seven o'clock
this is a special edition of skyny's
breakfast i'm jane secker live from
sanget just outside of calais
and i'm sally lockwood in dover
the french interior minister says the uk
isn't doing enough to help france tackle
illegal migration
five women and a child are among the
dead there's 27 people are killed trying
to cross the english channel at least
one first person is still thought to be
missing
french authorities arrest four suspected
people traffickers in connection with
the incident
protests through the night in calais as
demonstrators accuse the authorities of
not doing enough to respond to the
migrant crisis
shock and anger here in dover as a blame
game over the tragedy begins the french
accused britain of politicizing the
migrant issue for domestic gain boris
johnson says the uk and france must work
together to do more
i say to
our partners across the channel now is
the time for us all to step up to work
together to do everything we can
to break these gangs who are literally
getting away with
murder
the prime minister calls on the french
to agree to joint police patrols along
the french channel coast to stop people
smugglers
this morning we hear from one of the
traffickers who organizes these sorts of
crossings and a family determined to
reach europe
[Music]
hello good morning from sanget just
south of calais
on the french side of the channel and
this is the point yesterday that a
number of small boats left one of those
small boats sank not long after leaving
these shores 27 people we know to have
died including
a woman and five women and one child as
well as a teenage boy well in the last
few moments breaking news the french
interior minister has made some comments
uh about the british as handling of the
events uh let's talk to this guy's ali
fortescue who joins me now um ali what
has this man been saying so the
prejudice minister has effectively said
that we are not handling the britain is
not handling the migrant situation well
he said he's we're handling the
situation badly i think there will be
disappointment from some that already a
day since such a tragic event and
something that is above all a human
tragedy
there is a blame blame already being
sent over britain's way from france
because of course there is a difficult
relationship between france and britain
we know that and we know that each side
has been blaming the other and plenty
see that as not particularly useful
cooperation we know that the french have
effectively said that we're making the
route too attractive
the pull factors are too much for
migrants thinking of crossing the
channel and britain have blamed france
for not stepping up patrols enough on
the french side there are of course
enormous challenges to try to solve this
problem to try to police a 90-mile
stretch of coast we know that there was
a squabble too between britain and
france over 54 million pounds that was
going to be given here to step up
patrols we know that something that the
government have been looking at is
sending british authorities over here to
help with those patrols and we do know
that the french have been breaking up
migrant camps here in calais and dunkirk
more recently as well but that hasn't
stopped people desperate to make it
written desperate to cross the channel
and as we saw yesterday that is the risk
that authorities have been warning about
for such a long time 27 people losing
their lives trying to make it to britain
and home secretary pretty patel said she
wants to try to make this route unviable
charities say they want more safe routes
opened up for people fleeing persecution
but already this morning you have the
french interior minister saying that
britain needs to do more and i think
there will be a hope that what could
have come after yesterday would have
been
more cooperation something a bit more
useful than blaming and we know that the
french president emmanuel macron did
speak to boris johnson yesterday they
said no option is off the table so i
think people will be hoping for
constructive cooperation too indeed i
thanks very much jim we know that the
french interior minister has also said
that he would like to see
belgium and germany doing more as well
as the uk
following pleas from both sides of the
channel really to try to stop
this dreadful uh
series of deaths continuing this is the
highest number of people who've died in
this crossing in one day over the last
year our europe correspondent adam
parsons reports now from just up the
road here in calais on exactly what
happened
in the middle of the channel the remains
of a flimsy dinghy it had set off from
the french shore a few hours earlier
almost everyone who'd been on this boat
died
in these cold waters
one of the first people to reach the
scene in the middle of the channel was
lifeboatman
it was really dramatic there were
floating bodies so it was really very
shocking we recovered all the people we
saw and bought we recovered six people
all dead all day yes
there was one woman who said he was
pregnant and a young man in 18 to 20
years old and the rest were men
as on so so many other days hundreds of
people had left the french beaches in an
array of boats some seaworthy others
manifestly not fit for purpose
but this wasn't a day like any other
instead it was shrouded in death
in the hours that followed the french
interior minister the equivalent of the
home secretary came to the hospital here
in northern france he blamed people
smugglers and said britain and france
must cooperate more
we really have to work together
two major countries who are friends we
have to fight against these traffickers
together
and they play on our borders and sadly
our differences in legislation
sometimes this means there's a slight
lack of cooperation
possibly we are not working together
enough yet but we really must fight
against these criminals just as we fight
against terrorists
well the waters between here and
northern france and the british coast
are treacherous they're busy and at this
time of the year they're very cold
we've had near misses before a bad
accident was predictable but this loss
of life is clearly
terrible now a criminal investigation
has started a number of suspected people
smugglers have been arrested but the
question is how will this disaster
change the debate
about how france and the uk should
manage cross-channel migration
[Music]
britain has long claimed the french
should do more to stop these boats
leaving
last month we filmed these people
running down a beach near calais with
their boat heading for the uk
and watched by the french police who did
not intervene
but now political debate has coincided
with tragedy
[Music]
this area of northern france is dotted
with groups of people desperate to reach
the uk prepare to pay thousands to
smugglers and also to accept great risks
now those risks have come horribly true
adam parsons sky news calais
well in the last few moments uh the
french police have arrived where we are
uh the sun has just come up here uh at
calais
and they are sitting in a van looking
out across this water of course we know
that there are still at least one and
possibly more people
who are still missing from this boat
there are bodies out there in the water
and the police now uh patrolling at
various points along the coast in france
to try to see what they can see and also
of course acting as a deterrent to more
uh people smugglers and migrants who
would possibly today try to travel out
of course today the weather has turned
and that's thought to be one of the
reasons that so many people went out on
the water yesterday bad weather was
forecast the temperatures have plummeted
and the wind has picked up
it is not a calm day it is not the kind
of day you would want to launch a dinghy
out into the very gray choppy waters of
the english channel well a short while
ago i spoke to peter walsh from the
oxford university research unit migrant
observatory and asked him whether he
thought there were indeed any easy
solutions
i'm afraid there are no easy solutions
the government's main strategy so far
has been to throw money at the problem
to ramp up its cooperation in
france with the french authorities that
includes
increasing patrols on beaches and
anti-crime investigations to tackle the
smuggling gangs so far
we haven't seen uh that these measures
have brought much fruit but they will
take
some time to bite
really bringing to light i think just
the magnitude of the challenge
faced by the uk and french authorities
here
well as the political recriminations
start and we look to to possible
solutions to what happened yesterday
just along the coast uh just uh less
than a mile away from us at calais
at the port there there is a fleet of
private ambulances the bodies of those
who were brought ashore we believe are
still there they're going to be
transferred to lille today for
post-mortem examinations to be carried
out and for identification to begin
the two people who did survive
we know that they have told the
authorities that most of those on the
boat it's believed were from iraq and
somalia so we are getting more
information about the people that were
contained
on this boat yesterday that that
tragically sank with the loss of at
least 27 lives well they were trying of
course to get across the channel to the
uk sally lockwood is there on the other
side of the channel for us this morning
in dover
thank you jane yes certainly
soul-searching
this morning on both sides of the
channel and an emergency cobra meeting
was held in downing street night last
night
following this tragedy the prime
minister said people trafficking gangs
organizing these boats are literally
getting away with murder
and urged france to increase efforts to
stop the flow of migrants well skies
tamara cohen is at downing street
for us good morning to you tamara and
some comments from the french interior
minister
in the last few moments certainly uh
suggests that that could only inflame
tensions between the two sides this
morning
that's right sally i mean relations
between britain and france over this
issue have been very tense often
breaking out into hostile comments over
the last few months but these latest
comments from the french interior
minister speaking on the radio this
morning
say not only that the uk and other
european countries should do more to
help france tackle illegal migration
this is after the uk
offered millions of pounds to french
border force to help them with patrols
and has been really pushing the idea of
joint patrols with uk border force on
french beaches an idea which has perhaps
rather understandably been rejected by
the french side but the french interior
minister is also now hitting out the
uk's pull factor saying the uk is an
attractive destination for migrants and
that is really going to this has only
just happened in the last few minutes so
we haven't got a response specifically
to those comments yet but that's going
to really not go down well uh here in
downing street because
they say that we've seen these scenes of
french police watching as those migrant
boats set sail often and treacherous
conditions and they they know that
cooperation between the two sides is the
key to cracking this and this idea of
british personnel being sent over to
france they say has been rejected out of
hand by the french side so not clear
that tensions are going to calm down
today in the light of today's tragedy
now boris johnson chaired a cobra
meeting last night on this issue and i
think we can expect engagement with the
french government at all different
levels today but this issue has had
traction for some time i was told by a
senior uk government official that there
have been more meetings about small
boats over the last two years in number
10 than any other issue except covid the
reason that it hasn't
had
any effect on the small boats crossing
the channel is because it is so
difficult to do without cooperation with
the french and that whether that
actually happens over the next few days
is going to be the real test
okay tomorrow for now thank you
well we can take a look at this
morning's newspapers for you now and as
you might expect the front pages are
dominated by this tragedy in the channel
the headlines
highlighting the division on this issue
the metro asking why didn't france stop
them here's the telegraph which pictures
another migrant boat that was helped to
shore in dungeness yesterday
it's also the lead story for the
guardian which shows a mother helping
her children to the beach from another
boat in dungeness the eye describes the
victims as having died in search of a
better life the daily mirror reports on
how the lives of children are put at
risk as they cross the channel the
express quotes the prime minister saying
the smuggling gangs who prey on migrants
vulnerabilities are getting away with
murder the male has a very
similar headline while the times has
boris johnson describing himself as
shocked appalled and deeply saddened
the sun calls yesterday's events
shameful
and the tragedy is also the big story
for a number of papers in france
including liberacion they say the
channel is deadlier than ever and just a
note
that the death toll was revised down
from 31 to 27
after the newspapers went to print
now the incident is the worst of its
kind in the english channel since the
international organization for migration
began collecting data in 2014
and it comes amid a big crisis a big
increase in the numbers of people
attempting to cross to the uk by boat
our economics and data editor ed conway
has been looking at the scale of the
problem
now in the face of a tragedy like this
there's only so much you can learn for
numbers but it's worth just looking back
at some of the context you know how does
uh this situation compare in terms of
migrant crossings with previous years
how does it compare with other countries
and here's the picture compared over
time so we're just looking here at
cumulative channel crossings and the
higher these lines are the more
crossings there are over the course of
each year that's 2018 you can see 2019
just there 2020 you can see the line
getting higher but look at 2021 that
line considerably higher up now
to 25 792 so almost 26 000 of course
it's climbing uh more or less every day
that is the highest that we've seen in
any data series we have uh going back as
far as we have but it's worth just
comparing the uk with other countries
around the world we've seen those
pictures of course in spain and italy
and greece uh of many people crossing
into those countries so how does the uk
compare how does that 25
compared with greece well it's above
greece uh you can see this year this is
just this year so far greece 3500 or so
uh spain 36 000 so more than the uk so
far and in italy actually more than
double uh what we've seen thus far in
the uk
but of course it's worth also just
looking back in time so over time you
know the uk has been going up a bit but
compare that with these other countries
where has been much higher in fact i'm
just going to kind of change the axis
here so you can see look that's greece
there
and back in 2015 you were talking about
getting towards a million a year so
nearly a million a year much higher than
what we're seeing at the moment in the
uk but nonetheless pretty unprecedented
in the uk but looking overall at the
picture for asylum seekers asylum
applications actually the uk this is
compared with other countries in europe
the uk relatively low when you compare
it to head of the population when it
comes to overall asylum applications but
still when you're looking at channel
crossings we've really never seen a year
quite like this
well earlier i asked tim nor hilton
chief executive of refugee action
whether he was hopeful
politicians would use yesterday's deaths
to priority prioritize the safety of
migrants
at the moment where all we're hearing is
about tough action and what we know with
tough action is that all it does is play
into the hands of the people smugglers
increase the success of their business
model are you the complete opposite of
what um the stated intentions are and
the actual experiences of people
themselves making these crossings are
completely ignored these are people
fleeing persecution and human rights
abuses and yet they're dying in the
waters around this country the the
failure to address this and to allow
this to happen yesterday should be a
moment of national shame
and laura bundock is with me now in
dover laura we're learning more now
about
the desperate conditions these people
were in yesterday one french rescuer
describing how the handle of the boat
came off in his hand the glue he said
was barely dry we're also learning more
detail about some of those desperate
people who died yesterday yeah and we
know that they were some of them were
iraqi you imagine they were iraqi kurds
and some are from somalia as well
um it was an incredible morning a lot of
boats were taking off from france
yesterday it was one that was filmed in
a beach not far from berlin making the
journey you could see in the early hours
a group of people walking across the
sand there were children among this
great group wading out into the water
the inflatable did not look seaworthy
they never do
the life jackets they were wearing those
that had them on are very very rarely
adequate either these are the desperate
sorts of conditions that the the people
trafficking gangs are subjecting um
these poor people to as they start these
awful journeys and there is a desperate
sense of inevitability i think about
this we know that the number of people
making the crossing from france has been
going up this year um so far today
they've been around 26 000 people coming
over that's three times the number it
was at the same point last year the
reason why in november
we're getting more people coming over i
think is because although it's cold and
it's wet the conditions out in the
channel are relatively calm at the
moment and the threat of bad weather
this weekend i think has pushed many
people to the beaches to try and get
across before that wilder weather this
weekend really hits in but lots of
questions now about what can be done i
mean the boat journey is seen as one of
the only options for people who want to
arrive in the uk to try and claim asylum
lots of questions about the systems that
need to be in place to help people the
sorts of things and strategies that will
needs be in place to tackle these
illegal gangs that are operating and not
just from the french shoreline but
really along the whole length of the
migrant route really right from the very
start of these dangerous journeys i
think the time for political posturing
feels like it is over although we've
heard some strong language coming from
the french interior minister saying that
the handling so far has been bad that
the uk needs to do more that belgium
needs to do more as well
but i think as i say the time for this
sort of political language is over
there'll be a lot of pressure on the
politicians to come up with some
solutions to stop the gangs and to
prevent more people losing their lives
in this way laura for now thank you
well many of the people attempting to
cross the channel on migrant boats begin
their journey thousands of miles away
and most have been helped by an
organized network of people smugglers
sky news has spoken to one in northern
iraq who told us how he packs flimsy
boats with dozens of people trying to
reach britain well aware that some of
them simply won't survive the journey
despite the risks there are many
determined to take that journey with
their families our middle east
correspondent aleister bunkel reports
from urbel in iraqi kurdistan
this is one of iraq's people smugglers
he calls himself rasda
it's a fake name and he won't let us
meet near his home or film his face
he's
he's on his phone to contacts across the
smuggling network arranging documents
and travel for people wanting to escape
iraq for europe
he uses a cheap burner phone that can't
be traced regularly switching between
hundreds of sim cards and he tells us
how they cram people onto small boats to
reach the uk
[Music]
[Music]
that has made him a rich man
last year he tells us he made a hundred
thousand dollars
he isn't ashamed of what he does and he
is prepared to risk other people's lives
for money including the migrants trying
to get to britain
you are just exploiting are you not
their desperation
the mahmoud family paid smugglers 30 000
to get them to europe in september they
traveled via turkey and on to belarus
sleeping rough some of the way
shows me how she got down and kissed the
ground when she crossed into poland
days later though they were caught and
put straight back on a plane to iraq
they are now living in a tiny rented
flat because the smuggling gangs took
everything they had
because we don't have like in here and
we don't have future and we don't have
money we don't have we lost everything
okay
no
she's crying
and every time
she can't sleep
there are thousands of people like this
who will pay whatever it costs and risk
whatever it takes to start a new life in
europe
and encouraging them from the shadows of
the smugglers who take their money and
don't care less what happens to them
aleister bunker sky news iraq
well there were a number of small boat
crossings attempted yesterday and it
thought that those trying to make it
across the channel wanted to take
advantage of that window of calm weather
before it changed and we can now take
you to today's weather forecast
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's turning colder with wintry hazards
and very strong winds likely especially
on friday and saturday before then
though inland areas we'll have a mainly
sunny cold start today but a stiff wind
will keep it frost free exposed coastal
counties will see showers wintry on the
hills the morning will be mainly fine
but further blustery showers will run
into exposed coastal areas bringing more
snow to the hills and to lower levels in
the far north it'll be cold with a raw
wind
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back to sky news live from dover
and also cali this morning following
those tragic
events in the channel yesterday the most
deadly incident involving migrants
attempting
to cross the channel
to reach the uk in recent
years and the tragedy
in the channel comes just as the house
of lords is due to debate the number of
migrants
coming to the uk by boat now joining us
is baroness kate hoey
a former labour mp who is leading the
debate a very good morning to you first
could i get your reaction to the
comments from the french interior
minister in the last hour who has blamed
the uk for its handling of the migrant
situation
well good morning and i think it's
rather regrettable isn't it that the
first thing we wake up to
is another blame game and i'm very
disappointed that the french interior
minister has said that in the way he has
clearly the prime minister spoke last
night to
president macron and i would have hoped
that from that there would have been an
opportunity now for the two countries to
really work together because that's
what's needed now this cannot be solved
by us alone we can do lots of things and
that's part of the debate today where we
were going to discuss
many of the things that perhaps we could
be doing better but without the french
really trying to prevent
these migrants getting onto the boats in
the first place
we're not even in a situation where we
can discuss how things could be made
even better
and what do you hope will be achieved
in this debate today on the issue of
migration of course it comes in the
backdrop of this horrific incident
yesterday do you think that the language
around migration needs to change these
people described as migrants are human
beings and 27 of them lost their lives
yesterday
yes and of course over the past year or
so many people have been warning that
this was something that could happen if
the situation was not addressed i mean
my debate today was was put in for some
time ago of course it i i wanted really
today to make sure that we were going to
raise the issue of the concern that
there was life was threatened but also
what we as a country could do more i
visited dover
the other week and saw for myself how
these people are treated and of course
they are treated absolutely as you would
expect in our country extremely well but
then i looked at some of the pictures of
what was happening in the french camps
and when you see them being broken up by
the police and all their all the very
small holdings that they've got being
taken away from them you can understand
why many many of them even if they
hadn't particularly wanted to come to
our country do want to come but the
reality is we can't take everyone we
have to get a situation where the rest
of europe these people have come through
many many other countries in the eu and
therefore you know they are not
initially certainly can be seen as
asylum seekers but of course that is
something that once they're here um
there is an examination of that and of
course the whole home office situation
which i'm sure will get addressed today
has to be addressed because you know for
many many years people have said the
home office and the the whole way that
the immigration system is working is not
working i think john reed it was our
labor secretary of state years ago said
that it wasn't fit for purpose well it
still isn't fit for purpose and that
means that many people are waiting a
very very long time
so our hotels are getting full uh people
are being uh
moved on into accommodation up in houses
and flats up in the north of england
without anyone asking about that and so
it's not just a question of language at
all it's a question of whether how we
can as a government re
really treat this issue as something
that is serious and i'm you know the the
terrible terrible thing is that maybe
maybe in it it would be one
it's you can't even say good thing but
one thing that might come out of what
dreadful dreadful tragedy last night and
remember it's going to be very difficult
sometimes to trace the families of those
people because one of the things that we
know is that they don't have papers even
if they'd manage to keep them with them
those papers will be destroyed but one
thing that must come out of this is a
united effort now by our country by
france by belgium by germany to actually
realize that this can't go on and we
can't treat it the way we've been doing
and baroness ho you were a vocal
supporter of brexit we now have a
conservative government who won the last
general election very much on the issue
of taking back control
is this what taking back control looks
like
well of course this is not we have not
taken back control of our border and
over and it does seem absolutely amazing
that over the past year or so we haven't
been able to stop this in in a way that
is is sensitive to the needs of some of
these very very poor people who are who
are actually
you know coming because they are leaving
sometimes very difficult situations but
when i was down there what we did see
was the vast majority of them the vast
majority are young men uh aged
18 to 25 um they have not necessarily
fleeing from tyranny and torture
they are coming because they want a
better life and that we can understand
but we can't just have an open border
for people to come so we have to get
control of our border path and yes i i
you know one of the crucial things about
leaving your opinion was that we would
be able to make our own decisions on
this and that's what now i think we have
to concentrate on
now relations with france are not
exactly at their best but we are now
talking about some of the most desperate
people in the world taking enormous
risks and losing their lives to try and
reach the uk we're talking about
families we're talking about children as
a country we can be doing better than
this can't we
well i think as a country actually we're
a very very tolerant country and if we
look at the people that we brought in
from hong kong over the years we we were
very very good about bringing people
from uganda when they
put people out we've taken syrian
refugees we've taken you know thousands
of children unaccompanied children these
these are things we're doing i really
will not i think it's quite wrong and i
find it very disappointing that so many
of the agencies that are dealing with
refugees and and asylum seekers and
migrants as we would talk about that
they're actually wanting to blame our
country always you know it's always our
fault and of course this particular
tragic incident very clear that the
police was on those beaches and allowing
people to get on the boats and france
really has to take i mean i don't want
to just have this disciplined game as
well but i think france has to take
great responsibility and those people in
our country who are who are speaking up
for refugees need to be more serious
about where they're putting the
responsibility
and just lastly before i let you go we
hear
that this is the government's number one
priority is that because they are
concerned about the humanitarian aspect
of this and the safety of migrants or is
it is it about the optics of these boats
arriving onto uk shores on almost a
daily occurrence now
well one of the things i was you know
going to say in the in the debate today
is you know we have there's not been a
debate in parliament's house of lords
and there has been some questions
there's been no debate out in the
country from some time this has been a
really really uh live issue where people
are talking and governments have to take
responsibility and when people out in
the country not in the rarified
atmosphere of westminster perhaps have
been talking about it in the same way
then government has a responsibility to
listen to that and to act so i think i
think it should be now obviously covert
has been hugely uh you know the the
issue over the past year but i really do
believe that this night has to be
something and it should have been
happening even without this tragic
incident it really should be top of the
priority list at dining street
okay baroness harry thank you very much
indeed for joining us today
and following those tragic events in the
channel yesterday there's soul-searching
on both sides of the channel this
morning but that hasn't stopped
the political mud slinging between
the uk and france let's cross now
to jane secker in cali
thanks very much sally yeah we've heard
quite a lot from the french interior
minister uh this morning so far already
he's given the information that he's
able to about what happened yesterday a
couple of bits of breaking news from him
uh he has said that he believes that the
boat was bought in germany the boat that
sank yesterday just off the coast here
um and also that the people smuggler who
was involved with that had a german
registered vehicle so it is possible
that the route uh to this beach and and
to the beaches along this part of france
came via germany we know that four
people were arrested on the border
almost between uh france and belgium up
past dunkirk last night and that two
people have already appeared in court as
a result but that is the latest on the
on the facts what we know yesterday also
the french interior minister has
revealed that uh what they've been able
to glean uh from from the bodies that
they recover from the water and from the
two survivors is that those on the boat
yesterday were of iraqi and somali
origin but as uh sally was saying there
has been a certain amount of mudslinging
he has criticized the british for not
doing enough also criticized uh the
belgium authorities and the german
authorities for not doing enough to stop
the people smugglers as well uh let's
bring in now uh
for uh the
mp for la republique omash
for the rhone area bruno bonnell
now bruno i understand you were
listening to it to kate ho's interview
there um shaking your head what do you
make of what kate hoey responded to that
it's disappointing that the french are
appearing to point the fingers at
different countries
well is it really time to point fingers
when we have uh 27 people
uh dead in in the channel is it time to
say that there is a right border and a
wrong border is it really
the issue is it the time to uh just not
fight together against those smugglers
because really the message that our
minister was trying to send and maybe
uh it was uh it was twisted in a way
that may seem aggressive towards the uk
authorities but the message is we should
fight together on two phones one is the
smugglers we capture on the french
border we capture 1500 smugglers
since the beginning of the year
start number two
create the conditions so that the
migrants don't
stop to be obsessed by joining the uk
borders the reasons are complex maybe
there are some myths maybe there are
some regulation there but effectively
those migrants concentrate on the french
border coming from belgium coming from
germany coming everywhere and they try
to cross it on those long boats and they
paid smugglers for this so really i'm
upset by saying that it is no time to
fight between allies and friends it's
time to join forces to stop this traffic
of human being at this point
um but but there will be those who who
who look to what has been done in this
particular part of france uh we know
that the the uh the jungle the sanget
migrant camp was of course closed down
and that any migrants who gather here
are being moved on by the authorities
here in france
there will be people on the uk side
looking at the situation here and saying
why don't the french authorities do more
to help these people settle in france so
why don't the french authorities do more
to help these people settle in other
parts of the
of europe why do these people feel that
they need to take this dangerous journey
to escape from what is
a safe country
well
first of all we do spend a tremendous
amount of money and resources to try to
give them the better possible the better
possible life and i understand and
respect the fact that it would be
probably uh uh if we could we would be
more we would put more money or more
resources on this but there is a limit
to every single uh possible budget in
any single country including the uk
secondly uh settling those people in
france well they just don't want it they
want to reach the uk and there are many
reasons for this first language
a lot of people
have a basic understanding of english
and they feel more comfortable finding a
job there secondly is because they they
heard from any sources that the
conditions there are are better than in
in different european countries again we
need to harmonize those so that they
don't dream about being
on
workers in the uk
i think we i think we're losing you uh
bruno bonnell can you still hear me at
all
yes yes i can of course i'm sorry sorry
apologies you were you were saying about
that the fact that that we do need uh
you know there is an unlimited amount of
money but the british authorities have
put in 54 million pounds to help the
french authorities patrol uh this area i
mean it is a
100 or so mars of beach but it shouldn't
be beyond the wit of man should it not
to patrol this area and stop people
getting into the water in small boats
yeah but we do it i mean let's be
serious on 30 000 people try to cross
the channel 60 of them were arrested it
happens at night on small beaches police
can't be any everywhere i mean let's be
realistic let's stop telling people that
we can just close this border it just it
just won't so we have a result right now
at 60
not enough fair enough but but we we do
try and again pointing fingers at the
french people trying to help those
migrants crossing the channel just a
myth may the fact is that we face a
common problem we should join forces to
resolve it on many many issues probably
more money
but at the same time create the
conditions that the smugglers stop
telling tales about the uk paradise that
the migrants have in their in their mind
i mean just to be clear it's the french
interior minister who appears to be
pointing the finger this morning at both
the uk government and also uh the
belgian and the german government do you
think that the french government is
responding to this uh politically um
in a way perhaps
to try to change things i'm thinking of
other issues that are also on the table
at the moment things like fishing rights
between france and and the uk
do you think this is informing some of
the dialogue that we're hearing this
morning
well definitely i mean the brexit
situation that we we accepted because it
was a decision by the by the uk
population creates new conditions and
there are adjustments to be made but
again i don't want the people to feel
like the migrants are a piece of the
deal
between eu and and the uk the again i
heard this morning someone saying stop
saying migrants but let's start talking
about human beings trying to get a
better life i think that no people i
mean on both sides of the channel would
accept the idea that those people could
be taken as token for a negotiation
indeed brina bonnell uh an amash mp for
the rhone thank you very much for
joining us uh this morning well in the
last half an hour or so we've seen the
french authorities come down onto this
beach there's been a patrol of of some
uh six men and women who walked along
the beach
i mean
what are they looking for are they
looking for bodies are they just simply
looking to see whether it looks like any
more people smugglers maybe trying to
access the waters here we don't know but
you can also possibly see behind me one
of the big fairies now we don't know
what caused this dinghy yesterday to
capsize
we know that potentially it could have
been because it was such a a very very
small dinghy and it was being described
by one french minister as something like
a paddling pool you put up in your
garden and it may have just deflated but
there are also reports that it could
have been hit by one of these large
ships it is the busiest shipping lane in
the world
and it is very very busy again this
morning as it is
always well coming up on sky news
breakfast we'll be getting more reaction
to yesterday's tragedy here in the
channel and we'll speak to a former
political refugee
[Music]
welcome back to dover following the
worst incident involving migrants
in the channel yesterday afternoon
the number of dead is 27 people
including several women
uh and a young girl now we're just
receiving some lines at the moment uh
the french interior minister speaking on
french radio in the last few moments
has said that a fifth smuggler was
arrested overnight and that the boat
that was used in this
awful crossing uh was purchased in
germany and that the people smuggler had
a german vehicle registration those
lines coming out of france in the last
few moments
but let's move on to our next guest now
who emigrated to the uk as a political
refugee 14 years ago and now travels to
schools to teach children about why
people choose to leave their countries
and families behind
for a better life i'm joined now by
educator and co-founder of my bright
kite gulwali passalai a very warm
welcome to you thank you for joining us
now you left
afghanistan in 2007 if i'm not mistaken
and passed through several countries uh
on your way here to the uk making a
dangerous crossing by boat what was it
that made you so determined to reach the
uk
uh can i firstly say i didn't i didn't
migrate it i was forced to flee because
of the war and conflict and what made me
determined to get to the uk was
supposedly my brother was here and
unfortunately i was unwelcome across
half of the world the only place i was
treated as a human being and as a child
was italy by then i knew my brother was
in britain so i continued to the uk i
would have stayed anywhere where i was
welcomed sadly i was in prison deported
and had a terrible experience on this
journey across 2000 miles or so it took
me over a year at the age of 12.
it indeed sounds like a harrowing
experience what was it like making that
crossing to the uk by boat
i spent about a month in cali it was a
hellish place it was a place humor
should not be there it's a shame that
place exists even now after 14 years
i've been in britain
it was humiliating it was cold we used
to get harassed by the french police on
a daily basis our blankets would be
taken away we would be tear gassed and
sadly even now i know that it's done
with british taxpayer money and the uk
government's support and so yes
kali was not a place for humans to be
there and i think we have a moral legal
obligation to the people who are
stranded there and it's tragic that
these people have lost their lives
because of our hostile uh policies our
cruel and humane immigration system that
exists where we criminalize people and
dehumanize them for seeking protection
and asylum which is their human right
and once you did make it here safely
what was your experience of the asylum
system here in the uk
i did not lost hope on the journey of a
year across nine countries also and
across half of the world i lost hope
when i was in britain i was physically
well looked after by social services in
kent but mentally i was disturbed my age
was not not believed my nationality was
disputed by the home office the system
was demoralizing dehumanizing i was seen
as a suspect as a criminal uh it took me
five years to get my refugee status it
took me 13 years to get my citizenship i
was a
being in the uk was a lot more hard at
dealing with the bureaucracy than
dealing with smugglers and being on this
you know terrible ordeal in this journey
uh
across europe
and just very briefly we're seeing a
large number of crossings at the moment
what is the best thing and the best way
of supporting people arriving here in
the uk in your experience
i think the uk focused too much on
deterrence and and making people not
come here the government wants to stop
people coming here we had to find an
alternative we had to provide safe
passage for people we had to provide
humanitarian corridors unfortunately
they are not safer rules for people to
come they are not regular routes by
people to come and claim asylum in
britain again they're not doing anything
illegal they're just so desperate human
beings in our doorsteps we could do
better we are a compassionate country i
cross i travel across britain i see
people are kind people are generous i
think parliament does not government
does not reflect the views of the people
i feel like we have to provide
humanitarian reasons we have to give
people better alternative than smugglers
because you know going up to smugglers
in in gangs and so on and so forth is
good good but it wouldn't make a
difference because we have not provided
any alternative these people who are
stranded and wants to come here to the
uk for whatever reason we take a very
small number of refugees compared to
other countries we could do a lot better
we should be leading in this
humanitarian crisis and i'm afraid
we will see more stories like this i'm
heartbroken
we will have to leave it there
thank you very much for your insight
thank you
do stay with us we will bring you more
at the top of the hour
on the tragic events that took place in
the channel